Luke 24:13 through 27 that very day two
of them were going to a village named
Emmaus about seven miles from Jerusalem
and they were talking with each other
about all these things that had happened
while they were talking and discussing
together Jesus himself drew near and
went with them but their eyes were kept
from recognizing him and he said to them
what is this conversation that you were
holding with each other as you walk and
they stood still looking sad then one of
them named Cleopas answered him are you
the only visitor to Jerusalem who does
not know the things that have happened
there in these days and he said to them
what things and they said to him
concerning Jesus of Nazareth a man who
was a prophet mighty in deed and word
before God and all the people and how
our chief priests and rulers delivered
him up to be condemned to death and
crucified him but we had hopes that he
was the one to redeem Israel yes and
besides all this it is now the third day
since these things happened
morover some women of our company amazed
us they were at the tomb early in the
morning and when they did not find his
body they came back saying that they had
even seen a vision of angels who said
that he was alive some of those who were
with us went to the tomb and found it
just as the women had said but him they
did not see and he said to them o
foolish ones and slow of heart to
believe all that the prophets have
spoken was it not necessary that the
Christ should suffer these things and
enter into his glory and beginning with
Moses and all the prophets he
interpreted to them in all the
Scriptures the things concerning himself
Alleluia Christ is risen the Lord is
risen indeed Alleluia that great Easter
Anthem I never get tired of saying in
any every year one of my favorite
stories in the scriptures captures the
moment when Jesus the resurrected Jesus
encounters some of his disciples on the
road to Emmaus he has risen in fact the
text tells us it was that very same day
this is the first Easter Sunday but his
disciples interesting
don't recognize him I love our Lord's
coyness I can almost see him doing it
with a playful slightly veiled smile as
he asks them what it is that they're
talking about surely he knows that on
any big news day as anybody as everybody
has just experienced they're only gonna
be talking about that and so naturally
his disciples respond in that way are
you the only visitor to Jerusalem who
hasn't heard about these things that
have come to pass again he pushes them
again I imagine with a smile what things
and they said to him concerning Jesus of
Nazareth a man who was a prophet mighty
in deed and word before God and all the
people and how our chief priests and
rulers delivered him up to be condemned
to death and crucified him but we had
hoped that he was the one to redeem
Israel here they betray themselves they
are so distraught by what has just
happened
their eyes are limited by a merely
earthly a merely material vision they
cannot see what God is up to and they
say here that they had hoped they had
hoped
past tense that means they hope no
longer how could this Jesus be the
Messiah the Messiah is not going to go
and get himself killed
certainly not by these pagan Romans no
the true Messiah is going to show those
idolaters what's what and vindicate the
true God's true people before their very
eyes
Jesus can't possibly be the one that
they were waiting for and yet as they go
on they describe how several over the
women of their company claimed that he
was risen that several of his disciples
went to the tomb and did not find his
body there and yet they still can't see
it they still can't believe they still
can't see beyond their own frail human
vision and so our Lord
reads them in to the great mystery and
he said to them o foolish ones and slow
of heart to believe all that the
prophets have spoken was it not
necessary that the Christ should suffer
these things and then enter into his
glory and beginning with Moses and all
the prophets he interpreted to them all
the
things in the scripture concerning
himself he then tells them starting in
Genesis working up to the present day
how all scripture points to the life of
Jesus Christ
man when I give anything to have able to
hear that first Easter sermon it always
amazes me that Jesus is amazed by lack
of belief by failure of imagination
among his disciples and on the road to
Emmaus he continues to be amazed by the
unbelief of these disciples again and
again he tries to explain to them that
this must be how it goes down and yet
none of them see it but that's precisely
why it amazes me how can Jesus be so
struck by the unbelief of his generation
when literally no one saw the Messiah
story going down the way it did now of
course Jesus proceeds to reveal himself
to these disciples as the story
progresses and we know the story well
but I want to focus now on the
surprising nature of this first
encounter of course we modern Christians
we know how the story ends we know how
good friday leads to Easter Sunday in
fact we know better than this we know
that you can't get to Easter without
going through Good Friday but the fact
that we know the story so well actually
inoculates us to it's surprising power
that surprising moment for these first
generation disciples who did not see it
going this way and we need to remember
that nothing illustrates God's a coy
playfulness with us his creatures than
the resurrection of his son Jesus
Christ's we need to remember this fact
today now we are always to remember it
we should always remember just what God
is capable of doing just how much God
loves reversals just how playful our God
is how much he loves surprises how much
she loves showing forth his strength in
the weak things of our world but it's
especially appropriate that we should
remember it now as we celebrate Easter
Sunday in the midst of a global pandemic
because now we see that Easter is not
really about packed churches or dining
room tables full of people Easter
doesn't depend on our contributions at
all
Easter rather is made what it is by what
God can do by what God has done for us
in Jesus Christ's and it was surprising
to the whole world he redeemed sinful
men now this is good news for us for all
kinds of reasons but for today at least
it's good for us because we need to see
that our joy in this season is not based
on our earthly circumstances it's not
based on our ability to celebrate as we
would like but it's based instead on
what God is capable of doing in the
midst of our suffering it's made
possible because of what God is capable
of bringing about and so even in the
midst of this great sickness let us
rejoice and be glad and our God for
truly our Lord is risen today